is it better to start small or think big
and my answer would be
both
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers peter who's trying to
start a gym
and he's unsure of if he should start
small rent from other locations and
build up from there or
think big and create his own place from
scratch exactly how he wants it and
continue to launch new businesses from
there and my answer really is to combine
them
so what i would love for you to do
is start small
but then also have that big vision big
picture in mind
here's the reason okay this is real talk
this is important because a lot of
entrepreneurs
think they have to start big
and it's possible and you can you can
have success doing it
the challenge is when you start right
away
big
your chances of failure go up
dramatically because you don't know what
you're doing
you have a concept in your head and
that's great but things are rarely
they rarely work out as you think they
will every time every successful
entrepreneur who's built a business plan
that business plan changes a thousand
times before they end up hitting their
success because the assumptions that you
make are wrong
most of the time
so if you've never done this before if
you've never built a huge business and
you start by going big
you're probably going to make a lot of
mistakes
you're probably going to have some
incorrect assumptions and as a result
your business will fail
and the reason why it's so important is
because if you're investing your life
savings you know if you're mortgaging
your house if you're taking on investors
you can't afford for it to fail
at least i wouldn't if it were my
business if i was taking out a mortgage
or borrowing money from my friends and
family i would want to make darn sure
that that business
had the best shot of success
so i always encourage entrepreneurs to
start small to test
to test your your thoughts to test your
assumptions see if what you think will
work actually works
because you don't know until you
actually get out there and start doing
something
you test small
you show that it works you keep making
improvements you listen to your
customers and keep building up
keep investing back into your business
and then when you have something that
you know works you can raise the money
you need to blow it up
you know if you can get one gym working
really effectively
and that starts from renting from these
other gyms and then building yourself up
if you can get it to the point of one
gym being amazing then you can raise
money to expand you have a formula that
works and it's built on something real
and it dramatically increases the
chances of you being successful
here's a quick example that that can
really relate to what you're doing i'm
an investor in a salsa dancing business
here in toronto
the company is called toronto dance
salsa and how it started was just
renting from gyms
in their off hours so they teach
people how to dance salsa and it'd be
like six to nine at night type of thing
the rent was super cheap
and the founder
didn't have any business experience
before this
she worked in hotels and had
a great corporate life but had never
been an entrepreneur
and so she'd learn the ropes
on a small scale
by building up
classes
from these gyms
and she got to different locations
and she tested her model and she she not
only improved herself as an entrepreneur
learning the skills that you need to be
successful but also learning what it
takes to build a successful salsa
company
how do you teach students what's your
methodology what's the sequence you're
going to teach them in how do you make
sure people come back and stay motivated
although that you can't tell until you
actually go out and start doing it so
she did it on a small scale then
worked with different gyms open up
different locations still renting still
only paying an hourly fee
and she got to the point
where she could expand she had
confidence in the model
and went out and got her own location
in a mall
that cost over a hundred thousand
dollars a year
so instead of paying jim's 40 bucks an
hour she's now spending a hundred
thousand dollars plus per year to have
her location
but it works the business takes off she
teaches five to six thousand students a
year
how to become salsa dancers
but if she went out
took out a huge loan
talked to her family tried to go to
investors to get that hundred thousand
dollars plus just for rent
it wouldn't work there's too many things
that would have gone wrong in the
business all the trial and error
approaches that she took to get that far
wouldn't have been there and she would
have had to shut down and maybe be in
debt for the rest of her life
so start small
test see if it works and keep your big
picture in mind doesn't have to take you
that long to get there
but keep the big picture in mind i don't
want to see you struggling doing this
thing part-time for the rest of your
life
you know at some point you need to see
momentum of progress
and i know it's hard i know
as entrepreneurs we want to see things
happen you know we hate
being down in the details and the
operations and we have big visions and
it's hard to to wait
for things to happen
but it's so important
and it really comes out of me wanting
you to be successful and not having to
be in debt maybe for the rest of your
life and make one of the biggest
regrets of your entire life
by going big too soon
it can happen
but your chances of success go up
dramatically
if you start small and build up
believe
for those of you watching you like the
video
thumbs up below thank you so much and i
want to hear from you please leave a
comment underneath
if you like the video or if you have a
question for your own company i love
hearing from you and i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon
you